(crowd clapping)
- Oh, I love (inaudible).
Have y'all met before?
- No, we just have now.
- Okay.
- I like your Paisley's.
- You are-- uh, I did it for you.
- Oh did you? Thank you.
- So I cannot believe
we actually haven't met.
- I know.
- I've been at so many events with you
and your husband, Brad Paisley,
for everybody that didn't
know but everybody knows.
But I've just been at so many things
and I've never run into you.
- [Kimberly Williams-Paisley]
I know it's crazy.
- Yeah, anyway, nice to see you.
- It's so nice to see you.
- Glad we're meeting now.
Who cares about Brad?
So wait, I heard that you
were just at the White House.
- Oh my gosh.
So, well, I don't know if you can tell
but I'm having some vocal trouble.
- Yeah. You sound like you're whispering.
- I know. I don't mean to whisper
but it turns out I carry
tension in my voice.
- Yeah. Wait, does that happen?
I am freaking out right now.
- Don't freak out. It's gonna be fine.
- I'm a very stressful person.
- I'm doing all the things.
- Okay.
- But anyways, so Brad, my husband's like
he gets invited to the White House
to go play this Governor's Dinner.
- Yeah.
- Which is amazing. I'm so proud of him.
And it's a very like,
bipartisan event and everything.
He's like, so we're
going to the White House
and we're gonna sit at the table
with the Biden's and the governors.
And I was like, but I can't talk.
And my son Huck is like, it's okay, mom,
What are you worried about?
It's not like it's the
president of the United States.
I was like--
- [Kelly Clarkson] Actually.
- Actually it is.
So we go and I'm like nervous
and I meet Mr. President
and then I go turn
to the First Lady and she goes,
I'm sorry I've lost my voice.
And I was like, we're twinning.
- Oh my God. She didn't have a voice.
What are the chances?
- I know. I was so relieved
- God smiling down.
- It was. It was.
So, but anyway, it comes and goes.
- That's terrifying.
- No, but I'm getting treatment
at Vanderbilt Health and
everything's gonna be fine.
I'm gonna be fine, but I'm working on like
being authentic and being vulnerable and--
- Oh my gosh, I did not
even know this could happen.
Have you ever had
anything like this happen?
- No. I had like really bad
acid reflux and had to get some
(crowd laughing)
and it was like burning my
vocal cords and I had to get
like a sinus surgery to fix that
'cause I was losing my voice all the time.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Oh my gosh!
- I'm like talking,
which I'm really good at.
- [Kimberly Williams-Paisley] Yeah. Yeah.
- [Kelly Clarkson] You two
are terrifying me right now.
- But that's the stress thing.
I've never heard of that.
- It's the stress thing.
So I'm trying to like
breathe into my pelvic floor.
Have you ever tried that?
- Yes.
- Maybe in like yoga, the one time I went.
Wait, I heard that something happened
with your wedding ring. What happened?
- Well, so yeah.
This is how I know that I've
been married for 20 years
is my ring cracked.
- Oh my gosh.
- It broke. Yeah, so--
- Are you a very physical person
in general with your throat and your body?
Do you slam?
- I am. I'm very, very physical.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Me too.
- And after 20 years, you know, I just,
I got this little cut on my finger
and I was like, oh, it's my wedding ring.
Oh dear.
But anyway, so I'm not wearing it.
But yes, we're coming up on 20 years.
- [Kelly Clarkson] That's incredible.
(crowd cheering)
- Well, I wanna talk about
this 'cause when Brad was here
he said that you were starting a nonprofit
and it was called The Store.
- Yes! It's called The Store.
- It's really-- are
you in your third year?
- Yeah, third year.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Third year.
- It's a free referral based grocery store
for people facing food insecurity.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Yeah.
- We opened right before the pandemic
which was really perfect timing.
- I was gonna say very necessary.
- Yeah. Very necessary.
And um yeah, we've given
away at the new year
it was 2 billion-- 2 million meals.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Gosh.
(crowd cheering)
- And there's like, I mean there's a lot
of homelessness in Nashville.
Like I lived there for years.
Like there's a lot of need there.
- Yeah. And then food
prices have gone up so much.
So right now we're doing an egg campaign
because eggs are so expensive.
- [Kelly Clarkson] What happened?
One day I woke up and everyone
was talking about eggs.
I was like, what's happening?
- Yeah. But the whole idea is
that people can go into the
store and they can shop.
You know, then make choices
for their family instead of
getting a handout or something.
- Yeah.
And like healthy ones.
That's good. Like options.
That's cool.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- Well let's talk about the movie.
So what is it about, Jesus Revolution?
- Jesus revolution. Yeah.
So this is about a slice of
a historical moment in time.
It was like in the late
sixties, early seventies when
all the hippies and the
druggies were turning
to Jesus freaks.
And I play Greg Laurie's
mother, Greg Laurie's the star.
He's a preacher who became like
a big leader in the church.
And I play his mom who never
really got on the Jesus train.
So I have this like amazing
blonde Marilyn Monroe wig
and she was a smoker and a drinker and--
- That sounds like a
fun character to play.
- Seven husbands.
- Oh my God.
Like why continue to get married?
- She just kept trying.
- [Kelly Clarkson] That's
amazing. Very hopeful.
- Yeah. So I loved playing this part
and it's a really great movie.
- That's cool.